I don't think I ever really had the
expectation that hot Hollywood would be
a hospitable place for me as an actor I
knew going in that it would be the
struggle and it became apparent to me
very quickly as soon as I started wanted
to get into movies it became very clear
that those roles didn't exist and so
when they did exist I fought really hard
for them my name is Amanda Sandberg I'm
19 years old and I am most well known as
an actor I think it kind of became
something that I'd like to do amidst a
bunch of other things when I was younger
because I grew up in LA and it's not
that uncommon in Los Angeles to as a
child of go to audition interesting way
that you go to gymnastics practice or
tap or ballet so something that I did
for fun and became a passion as I grew
older I love you outside it's still
something that I feel like just now are
we starting to bridge the gaps in terms
of being able to have three-dimensional
nuanced black characters for young women
and I'm so lucky that that the work that
I've done in the past has led to me now
being able to play those roles
my advice to teenagers who are trying to
figure out life in social media is take
a break take a break when you need it
it's so easy to exist more in that world
than in real life it can be confusing
for your brain your body everything so I
think it's really important
we take out their breaks from spending
so much time on the internet there are
different reasons that I choose
different roles some are because the
roles and the projects are so compelling
and and I want to be part of them
because I care about them so much and I
feel away about every project but there
are other products that I feel like I
choose just because of the power of
being in that project and and what it
can mean to see a character that you
haven't quite seen before who is a young
black woman and so that's partially and
some of the reasons that I choose
certain things is being able to create
that representation is a very powerful
[Music]